[Music]
so as as you know this talk is about
learning credit networks with some
applications in financial but in
particular the banking industry and this
work I have done together with some
colleagues from ING and also at the
University so just by a show of hands
how many of you have some background in
finance or related to some financial
okay I think it's more than I expected
so that's good yes so just very briefly
about me I'm a trading quantitative
analyst within the financial markets in
ING Bank so I'm not officially a data
scientist but I still do a lot of things
with data and modeling in particular and
together with that I'm also a research
scientist so one day per week I spend at
the University in the informatics
Institute at the University of Amsterdam
so together with some PhDs and master's
rules we do also research which looks
into how can we apply let's say database
techniques or modeling techniques into
the banking environment yeah so my
supervisor at ING also happens to be a
professor at the University so Drona
condi and this really helps me to have a
good balance between academia and
industry and so far for me it's been
quite nice this this nice balance with
with what's going on in the industry and
what's happening in the research side of
things and just to briefly mention we
have financial support from these
organizations so so the Dutch
Organization for scientific research we
also have projects with KPMG and we are
supported by the European Union as well
so there's a project called
Big Data finance which looks into
applicability of these techniques into
trading and risk management so we also
do some research in conjunction with
that yeah and before I start so although
I'm a trading quant analyst this talk is
not about trading strategies or ways to
make money otherwise I wouldn't be
giving this talk here so just a small
this
claimer yeah so I'll start with
something which all of you know I mean
this is something which happened almost
ten years ago but people still talk
about it and people have changed quite a
lot of things because of this so what
happened was Lehman Brothers collapsed
it filed for bankruptcy and as a result
there was a widespread panic in the
entire financial world
so not just Lehman defaulted but the
entire market kind of stopped working
for for a while so lots of trading was
not happening after this this shock
happened and it really changed the way
that we do things within banks in
particular so within financial markets
this is really an event which
fundamentally changed things in a lot of
ways so my talk is also a bit about you
know what changed after this crisis and
how things are done in a different way
than what they used to be in the past so
but the question is why did the collapse
of one financial entity like Lehman for
example why did it have such huge
repercussions on the entire economy so
that's one and why did something which
started with something very small so it
was a subprime crisis people were
borrowing money to buy homes and then at
some point they did not have it have any
jobs so they stopped paying these loans
but then why would it affect something
like Lehman which had nothing to do with
mortgages or something like AIG which
was also not giving any money to home
owners so that's also a question you
know which people have thought about and
they were quite something's happening
let's say before the crisis which which
led to such huge repercussions so
there's a nice cartoon which says I
thought we were just buying a house but
then it led to this this whole
catastrophic collapse of the system and
one of the reasons why this happened at
such a big scale was because of the
inherent complexity in financial markets
so because of deregulations and because
of freedom provided to let's say banks
and financial institutions in general
what people did was they took small
residential mortgages so these small
houses that you see at the top are
people borrowing money for buying a
house but then what was done was that
these mortgages were packed into things
like residential mortgage-backed
securities and then again these
residential backed securities were
repackaged into what is called a CDO so
it's a it's a derivative we'll get into
what derivatives are but again I mean
what you see happening here is through
something which is as simple as a home
loan people constructed instruments
which were quite complex in their
structure but also it introduced
connections which are not present in the
market so if a bank somewhere in the US
is giving money to a homeowner the risk
of that particular homeowner is not just
restricted to the bank but it's
widespread in the economy because of
such financial instruments so things
really got out of hand as a result the
fact that something as small as
mortgages could be transformed into
something as complex as a CDO yeah so a
CDO is a fairly tricky financial product
and a lot of these videos were being
bought installed back in the crisis
period so also another thing that I want
to illustrate with this is that such
transactions introduced dependencies
between financial institutions so this
will be one feature that I'll be
focusing on in the rest of the talk how
can we capture this dependency and how
can we quantify this dependency while we
are pricing things and while we are
trying to determine the risk that we run
so so this is just the background so so
this is what I was saying I mean what
happened as a result was that after the
crisis people suddenly realize that
things don't happen in isolation in the
financial world people are really
interconnected to each other through
either financial contracts or through
ownerships
and this was a radical shift after the
after the crisis so people started to
realize the importance of systemic risk
so systemic risk refers to the risk of
the collapse of the entire system as
opposed to collapse of a single entity
and this was a risk which was really
shown to be present in the system as a
result of the crisis so so here on the
left you see an example of some
investigations that happened after the
crisis and this was generated by looking
at the equity data so who owns which
company if you own shares of a company
you own some part of that company and
this was a network constructed from that
ownership data and you see that at the
core of this network you have these big
banks as you would expect which owned a
majority of the entire network so they
also drive the decision making of the
financial institutions in that picture
on the right you see something which
people came up with again after the
crisis so this is called a debt rank the
idea is similar to PageRank in in Google
so with red rank you can quantify how
risky a financial institution is based
on its centrality in the network and
this helps you to quantify let's say if
an institution became more risky as the
crisis progressed so so these things
became more central in the research part
of the financial networks and there's a
very nice quote from Andrew Hardy
so he's the chief economist at Bank of
England and he gave a speech called
rethinking financial stability where he
said that financial systems are really
like complex networks where things do
look fairly stable when times are good
but as soon as there is some shock
introduced in the system there is
something called a tipping point and if
the system crosses that tipping point
the whole system kind of collapses as a
result of that
so what regulators are now trying to do
is to make sure by their policies that
you know financial networks
are resilient from a network perspective
as well so if let's say one bank
collapses it doesn't have this huge
repercussions in the economy which was
not the case before the crisis yeah so
I'll very briefly mentioned something
about derivatives because I assume not
all of you are familiar with that since
this is the core part of my talk and
then we will look at data and how can we
use data to quantify risk about
derivatives so very simply derivatives
are financial contracts which derive
their value from some underlying asset
yes so you can have a derivative on a
stock you can have a derivative on a
interest rate on a FX rate and so on and
the complexity of the derivative comes
from the fact that they derive their
value from the value of this underlying
asset so you can have a call option for
example on a Apple stock and what the
value of this Apple stock so you can
observe the value of your Apple stock in
the market let's say it's trading at
hundred euros how do you price a call
option which will allow you to buy a
call option in the future 400 euros
irrespective of the price of the Apple
stock at that time so how do you price
something like that it's very tricky
it's not very straightforward and then
what happened was that people from
Economic Sciences so these three famous
economists came up with a way to price
these options way back in 70s for which
they were awarded the Nobel price and as
a result these options suddenly became
quite popular so everyone could price
them through this no arbitrage I grew on
cumin which basically means that you
cannot take a risk less profit so as a
result what happened was that these
derivatives started being traded quite
quite frequently in the market so so
this is simply a a call option which
means that you have a contract which
allows you to buy the contract at the
strike price at the maturity of this
contract no matter
a stock value so let's say in six months
if the Apple stock is somewhere here 150
you can still buy it at 100 and make a
profit of 50 euros
another type of contracts which are very
popular are interest rate swaps so so
there what happens is that as a borrower
if you want no risk to the interest
rates if you want to hedge out that part
of your risk you would enter into a swap
contract where you would pay a fixed
rate and receive a floating rate so as a
borrower effectively you are paying a
fixed rate for any kind of loan and
these contracts are also hugely popular
in the market so you will be surprised
by the total market value of the
derivative trades in the world today so
any guesses about how much the value is
sorry five yes so it's it's actually 12
trillion and and this is after things
have declined quite a lot from the
crisis you see so here you have
different kinds of derivatives you have
interest rate affects commodity equity
credit and so on and the biggest portion
is interest rate derivatives as I
mentioned and this is 10k but it's
billions of you see so it's it's quite a
significant amount and there's a huge
market with lots of players in this
market who are actively trading this
derivatives on a daily basis so there's
a huge risk in the in the system and
even though let's say with crises and
regulations things have slowed down it's
still quite significant I would say and
it might be with these deregulations
which are being proposed that the trend
increases again so just as a comparison
India's GDP is 2 trillion so this is 6
times India's GDP so it's quite a lot I
mean lot not many people know about
derivatives but they do have a huge
market value and they are traded quite
actively in the market
yeah any questions so far about
derivatives or okay so so the reason I'm
talking about derivatives is because
after the crisis as I said the the
derivative market changed quite a lot
there were lots of regulations that were
introduced in order to deal with the
counterparty risk so the risk that your
counterparty might default in a contract
yeah so if you have a trade with let's
say Goldman Sachs in five years from now
Goldman Sachs might not exist this
became a reality this is something that
could happen so banks were asked by the
regulators to keep a reserve in order to
protect themselves against the
counterparty related losses and this is
what I've shown I mean you can have
expected and unexpected losses that the
banks calculate on a daily basis and
these losses depend on two things one is
how much can you lose and the other
thing is what's the likelihood of that
default of your counterparty so these
two things go in into this calculation
and for the first part what we do is we
simulate the market risk factors so
things like stocks and equities and
interest rates effects via a Monte Carlo
simulation and then we get a
distribution of what the exposure can be
in the future and based on this exposure
we calculate these measures so from an
engineering perspective this is also a
very interesting problem just to price
the CVA portfolio for ing for example
for a bank like ING you would need to do
approximately three point seven five
billion pricing valuations just for one
CVA run and that's why we have to do
things on CUDA instead of even C++ so we
use parallel programming and we program
things in the efficient way which can
allow us to calculate these measures in
an efficient way
yeah so again I mean for PI data I think
what's relevant more is let's say from
the data how can we quantify these Co
dependencies of financial institutions
to each other
so that's one of the key questions that
I have in my talk and so for that the
first thing that we need is how do banks
calculate the probability of default for
the measures that I just mentioned and
what banks use are something called
credit default swaps so these are also a
kind of derivative where let's say you
have a contract between the prediction
buyers so this buyer is selling a
serious contract to some sorry this this
person is selling a serious contract to
the buyer to insure this reference
entity yes so it's like buying an
insurance on your house and the more
costly the insurance is the more chances
are that your house might be robbed or
there might be some accidents with the
house let's say some fire and so on
so the market implied probability of
default of a counterparty can be
calculated from its CVS spread and as
you can see when there was a crisis in
Greece the debt crisis the serious of
Greece jumped quite a lot in the market
so it was trading at a very high price
which means that if you have to protect
yourself against the default of Greece
you have to pay a lot of money yeah
because a lot of people think that
Greece might default so so these CDSs
are a good way to infer the likelihood
of default of a counterparty but then
they're also quite controversial because
they were one of the central instruments
in the crisis and unlike insuring your
house what happens is that so when you
insure your house it's only one house
and there's only one insurance on it but
the c.d.s is a bit different because on
one reference entity you can have
thousands of CVS so it's like thousand
people buying insurance and selling
insurance on your house which sounds a
bit strange but it does exist yeah so so
even the Pope says that you know they
are unethical this was in the news this
was not a joke so this is from even ten
days ago I thought it was quite funny
because I'm not sure why he cares about
serious contracts in general but for us
it's good in the sense that it allows us
to calculate what the markets perception
Faye counterparties likelihood of
default is so as I said I mean the
questions that we have for our purposes
is how can we measure the co dependence
of default among our counterparties
because it's a network right so if you
are trading with let's say hundred
counterparties they are all not in
isolation they all have linkages they
all have connections between them and
let's say if one of our counterparty
defaults it's not just that counterparty
which is going to be affected it will
also affect lots of other counterparties
in that region so how can we really
quantify that and how can we bring that
into our pricing framework yeah so so
this is the main question that we have
as a risk management team and again I
mean this is a picture that is from
financial dot plot which shows so they
used a nice network representation to
show what would happen if if Deutsche
Bank for example defaulted its impact on
the other banks in the area so okay so
given that this is the question how do
we approach it and in order to do that
what we do is we look at a specific case
of the recent Russian financial crisis
so here we have the events in Russia
from almost two years ago when there was
the crimean invasion and well all these
cases with the flight being shot down
and at the same time what was happening
was that the oil prices was
significantly falling which caused the
ruble to deteriorate quite significantly
and if you look at this point in this
point the ruble almost fell half in its
in its value so so if you are a bank
trading with counterparties in that
region you are exposed to this huge
amount of risk because if you are
supposed to get payments in in rubles
what you are getting is going to be half
so you have to really account for these
situations that can happen and you also
have to know that if this happens with a
certain institution in that region
how is it going to propagate through the
system
so these are the two key questions that
that we have and apart from things going
in distress what also usually happens in
financial markets is that things again
don't happen in isolation so as you see
that the ruble is is going down in its
value the credit default swap of Gazprom
which is a Russian entity is going up at
the same time so on one hand you are
likely to lose a lot of money but then
at the same time the likelihood of you
you losing that more money is also
increasing here so this is what we call
wrong-way risk and this is again
something which happens due to inter
linkages in the financial market so in
order to quantify the inter-linkages
between our counterparties what we did
was we try to use a Bayesian network
with some modifications to the
methodology so I I'll just briefly go
over this nation network because I
assume some of you are already familiar
with this so Bayesian network is a
directed acyclic graph it looks
something like this where each of the
nodes represents some random variables
with some probability distributions and
the edges represent the direct
dependencies that you can have between
these random variables so what you try
to do is you try to learn these
structure first of all and you also try
to learn the parameters that you have in
this conditional probability
distribution and the good thing about
Bayesian network is that if you know
these parameters you can quantify the
conditional probability of a node
conditional on its parents yes so I can
say that the probability of the grass
being wick if the sprinkler is on and
the rain is also happening is is quite
high yeah and and so on so for all the
cases I would know a way to get the
likelihood of a certain node in the
system the other good thing is that the
joint probability distribution can be
presented in a very compact form so here
I can write the
joint probability distribution of all
the four variables in this very
simplistic form and the reason I can do
this is because of the dependencies that
I have learned over there so I know that
the node W only depends on SNR and not
on C for example I know that node s only
depends on C node are only depends on C
and so on so with this yeah so with this
you have a compact way to learn the
parameters and then use them to infer
your conditional probabilities so so you
can use something which is called a hill
climbing algorithm to do your structure
and the parameter learning and there are
packages which allow you to do it in a
very nice way so there is something
called PGM py in python and there's also
B and learn which helps you to do this
in a very easy way but the idea is that
you simply start with some graph and you
keep adding edges to it so that your
score and this can be some information
theoretic score increases as you
progress so this is the principle I'll
just show a very quick example I'm not
sure how much time I have but I have it
in this so so let's say you have these
structure there's a node X which is
related to both Y inside it points to
both Y insect and you have these
probabilities that you want to learn and
then you have this other example where
you have a V structure so you can simply
generate some some data and you can use
this data to infer what the structure
should be and this is quite easy the
only thing is that Python does not do a
great job so I don't know if I should
should say this in a PI data conference
but Python is not the best when it comes
to patient networks so you see that it
does a very good job in learning the
first network so it learns they're just
quite well and also the parameters are
quite well learnt but then in this case
it it learns the
so the opposite of what is actually the
case yeah so but with B and Learn you
can do a pretty good job so again I mean
this is an academic repository which is
maintained by somebody who is at Oxford
and he does a very good job at updating
this library with the most recent
developments in let's say Bayesian
statistics so I would highly recommend
being learned if you are trying to do
something with Bayesian networks okay
so coming back to our presentation so
again I mean the data that we go use in
order to detect dependencies is the
serious spreads and this is where we
have to do something special because we
can't just feed all this data into the
Learning Network because it's not
Gaussian the distribution is not caution
so what we did is we introduced a notion
of epsilon drops which simply measures
the points from which there are jumps in
the time series here so if this is a
local minima of your time series and if
the time series jumps from this local
minima to this point and if the jump is
bigger than a threshold that you can
decide to to be the standard deviation
in the last 15 days for example it can
detect those drops and it can tell you
which are the points of distress in the
time series yes so I know that these are
the points where the time series really
showed it to stress and for us this is
good to know because once we know the
distress for one entity we can do the
same for for two of them and you can
really see let's say if if this entity
is showing a distress on day D whether
the other entity is also showing you
distress on day t or not yeah or with a
delay so the blue dots here are the
distress in this orange time series
caused by the blue time series so these
overlap and then this is what we can
feed into our Bayesian network in order
to make it learn the parameters of the
network so it's a way to modify the
existing Bayesian
technology and make it suitable for our
purposes so once we feed in this epsilon
drops for two parts of the time series
so we do a calibration for a calm period
which is here and one for this
distressed period we get very
interesting results so the picture on
the left shows you a network in a very
calm state and there you don't see very
many darknet red nodes but on the right
which is a distressed period you see
that the top part of the network which
consists mainly of the oil companies
suddenly becomes concentrated in terms
of the stress that it has on the rest of
the network so these cells represent
conditional probabilities of each of
these nodes conditional on the default
of of this node yeah so so this will
tell you for example what's the
conditional probability of default of
this conditional on on this so from two
relationship so you really see that
there is a cluster which emerges in the
network and these are indeed the
companies which are systemic for that
region so if gas prom for example
defaults in Russia it will have huge
repercussions on other counterparties in
that region as well but something which
is so let's say this whip which is one
of the banks they're smaller banks there
it will not have such huge repercussions
so as a bank when we are trading with
these counterparties you would like to
adapt our charges depending on how risky
a counterparty is within that region so
this is how we use this conditional
probabilities and since these are
conditional probabilities we can
directly use them in our pricing and
risk management framework and that's why
we cannot use something like
correlations for example so we really
need probabilities which are conditional
on the default of the counterparty and
with this we can also construct nice
Network so here you see that if gas prom
is in stress it doesn't affect the
network's so much this is in a calm
period but in a crisis period you see
that suddenly all these notes that I
showed
to you in the top part of the heatmap
they become quite risky in the sense of
propagating stress and the stress also
propagates further in the network than
it did in the in the calm period so so
it really shows you with networks how
can you capture stress propagation yeah
so how can you measure dependence of
default of financial institutions and
then how can you adapt your risk
measures as a result of this and data is
is really key here because we cannot
know let's say these two companies will
not tell us if they are trading with
each other or not so the only way that
we can infer this is by looking at some
data related to these companies in the
market and then make all these
inferences based on that data so just to
conclude I mean this is again something
that I have said before but for the two
broad things that we calculate within FM
one is related to expected and the other
is related to the unexpected losses if
you take this system acress into account
the reserves are much higher than what
they should be which tells you that
banks when they're calculating these
measures they are not including the
system at risk in their calculations
which is bad because if something goes
wrong you will not have enough reserves
to deal with such a situation yes so you
should really try to integrate this
system acress which is present in the
system through some data driven
techniques into your pricing and risk
management so this is where I'll stop so
this is an ongoing work which I do
together with some colleagues and we
also publish it in some academic
journals so this is the article where
some of these results are based on and
if you are interested I can share this
with you
[Applause]
so any questions oh and over microphone
to a group here
I was wondering because I think with the
Bayesian networks you make the
assumption that they're a cyclical yes
is that a realistic assumption well if
you don't assume that they're cyclical
what can happen is that let's say if
there is a cycle this cycle will cause
you not to measure things accurately so
so this is a way to make sure that you
are quantifying stresses only in one
direction and anyway we are stressing
one node and trying to see its effect so
we we don't care if the stress hits this
node back to that same node that's one
of the reasons why we picked Bayesian
network oh sorry the patient way of
modeling things so I'm wondering how
many steps you need to consider - I mean
to assess all the risk like you're
defaulting and you're trading with me
but and trading with him and he's
trading with with with with the next and
so on right so how do you actually
propagate the till to the end or at some
point in drops down or do you have any
way of dealing with it yeah so if you
look at this picture I mean there's
something called shortest distance from
a node that you can compute in a network
and I would say that in this case it's
something between 3 to 4 so within 3 to
4 steps you can reach the entire network
if it's a small region so things are
pretty connected and one of the key
concepts in network theory is that you
have these hubs so for example if you
look at the social network there are
celebrities and you can connect to any
other person in the world with 6 links
or less and the reason you can do this
is because you would know somebody who
is a friend of somebody who is famous
and then through that you can reach a
lot of other people so the same thing
applies to financial networks as well if
you have a thousand banks not all of
them are equally risky I mean some are
much more risky than the others and some
are also trading a lot with other banks
so the stress can propagate
very quickly I mean that's one of the
reasons why things got so worst is there
to your knowledge or just a simple
explanation a way to incorporate for
examples the intuition of time series
analysis though so when you run this
analysis and you get the network but
let's say one bank sells its asset from
another institution can you tell the
system this happened this when you know
that there's a dependency that was lost
or I mean you can of course so that's a
indeed a difficult problem because banks
don't reveal to each other or in general
financial institutions don't have the
obligation to tell who they are trading
with so it's again I mean we are making
a big assumption by looking at this CDs
in assuming that when these two
institutions move together it's likely
that they are connected otherwise they
would not have a core movement so but
again I mean this is something that you
can try to it's a it's a difficult
problem to infer really may be time for
one final question
they look like two completely different
networks and their network in distress
what is the transformation between two
can you derive in some way the
transformation so with networks what you
can do is you can measure things like
degree distribution so one of the things
that has changed in that picture is that
some of the nodes have become bigger and
the size of the node represents how
connected this is to the other nodes so
things in distress become more connected
that's a feature that has been also
observed by some other researchers
that's one and also the stress
propagates to much larger distances than
it would in a in a less connected
network so you can statistically make a
distinction using some Network
statistics between
two structures you can do this and
usually what happens is that things
become more connected as as crisis is
about yes and no because the right
picture is much more interesting just
this one default starts are to happen
this pictures nuts but here also what we
did is we stress this node completely so
we calculate the so the color of the
node denotes conditional on the default
of this what's the likelihood of default
of this and the reason why you have less
red in this picture compared to that one
is because things were not so connected
here so the fact that here you have more
stress propagation to other nodes it's
an artifact of the reason that networks
did become more connected as thank you a
question the kind of different nature
can you could you comment on the choice
of CSS instead of equity prices or wrong
prices yes so this is because as I said
most of these measures that we calculate
use CD s as an input for calculation of
probability of default and therefore so
that's why they are called credit
networks I mean CD s is really represent
the credit quality of an institution so
if you would like to measure the credit
quality of one institution compared to
the other you would like to see how
their CD aces our comoving let's say
that's why you could use equity data as
well but it's not directly linked to the
credit quality that's why we use serious
and it's a fairly liquid market so the
volume is also quite big and these are
traded daily with quite some quotes in
volume so it reflects what's going on in
the market about these companies
[Applause]